starfleet command yes sir i love that
people still think of me in that role
and it's so because star trek has never
died what is it lieutenant malfunction
sir i don't think you could possibly
imagine
that a television show could have this
much impact on on so many people for so
long but it's wonderful
[Music]
in 1966 a black woman starring in a
prime time role with a diverse cast was
truly groundbreaking ms nichols played
lieutenant uhura on the starship
enterprise but in television history her
trailblazing role meant so much more the
first
important
non-stereotypical
role the first
michelle was considered one of tv's most
iconic pioneers but in her later years
she suffered from dementia and was
involved in a three-way conservatorship
battle between her son her close friend
and her former manager which resulted in
a lawsuit over her reported 8 million
estate and her health in 2015 i visited
the actress at her home after she had
suffered a stroke i have this thing
about so-called sickness
and
i can't say it about everything every
sickness but i i've always felt a little
girl
if you deny it it'll go away and it does
you're a fighter yeah oh yeah i'm a
fighter
i'm
i'm this kind of fighter
michelle showed that fighting spirit
after she almost quit star trek
following season one she was offered a
role on broadway but a very famous fan
changed her mind i turned around
straight into the face of dr martin
luther king
and nearly fainted
um he admired the show and told me how
much he admired my work and how
important it was
on television and i said well thank you
very much but i'm leaving the show and
dr king said you cannot you have changed
the face of television forever he said
it's more important that people who are
not black see this show see you in this
role
because they see us for the first time
as we should be seen as equals
she also broke barriers and made history
with this 1968 kiss with co-star william
shatner
[Music]
bill and i
laughed and joked about it
and then suddenly everyone was very
serious
the first interracial kiss
on television
and my attitude was so what
this is star trek we're in the future
well don't don't worry about it and
what happened was
that we got the most fan mail ever i
have a favorite story i tell i said yes
well
bill insisted on doing 36 takes to get
it right i'm a perfectionist you
understand so it's now up to about 70
because every time i see him and he
kisses me i go that's 37. that's 38.
that's 39.
that's 76.
this isn't reality
[Music]
this is fantasy
miss nichols inspired many integrating
nasa recruiting women and people of
color to take part in the space program
it was under contract to nasa to recruit
the women and
minority astronauts for the space
shuttle program and i developed others
aerospace educational programs and
projects
for
various agencies
a star for more than five decades
michelle's grace beauty and talent were
an inspiration for so many others who
would follow her path i have had letters
and have come in contact with young
women who
have said to me you came on and i
thought my god there's somebody there
representing me
[Music]
you